[Applaudissements]
merci saïd ahmad en tout cas bravo à lui
devenu franchement c'est déjà pas mal
c'est déjà pas mal bon ça va vous êtes
content oui voilà devenu hannon l'a fait
le buzz ben ouais c'est pas le but mais
bon si quand on fait un tweet en gaz
pour faire le buzz si ça permet de
parler notamment des familles qui
souffrent des réseaux et de ceux celles
qui meurt sous les balles j'en suis très
heureux alors vous êtes vous avez vu que
on a reçu donc la semaine dernière on a
reçu c'est qu'alors ils s'appliquent à
lord et c'était donc on a reçu deux
dealers inquiéter repenti est un autre
nom et vous avez dit voilà qu'on pouvait
pas faire ça à la télévision alors tout
le monde le fait parce que j'ai des
idées voilà je salut les terriens l'ex
mentor des frères kwasi repenti dans
salut les terriens été longtemps on aura
les extraits tout à l'heure on nantais
en direct il avait le reçu le voleur de
kim kardashian qu'on avait reçu
également ici vous avez vu sur le jt de
france 2 regardez il ya même un jeune
qui achètent sont pas sanitaires ils ont
mis ça dans le jt de france 2 on regarde
la tentation est grande de s'en procurer
un faux ce jeune homme qui préfère
rester anonyme en acheter 1 100 euros
sur internet en 15 minutes vous avez
sanitaires j'ai enregistré le qr code
sur mon l'application anti colvin de son
nouveau portable et après je suis allé
dans un restaurant pour voir si ça
marchait vraiment et le gaz a scanné
monde et ça fonctionnait préfèrent payer
ma liberté que comme faire vacciner
alors grâce aux tweets mine de rien de
saïd ahamada on se peut se poser une
vraie question est ce qu'on doit montrer
ce soir les choses la télévision est ce
qu'on doit aller recevoir sur le plateau
ou pas voilà on s'est un petit peu
accroché par voilà réseaux sociaux
interposés mais en vrai il a posé une
vraie question est ce qu'on doit les
recevoir ou pas où est-ce qu'on doit ne
pas recevoir ces gens là sur un plateau
en plateau vous votre position c'est de
ne pas les recevoir mais pour les gens
c'est pas le héros soit pourquoi
savez moi j'ai grandi dans les quartiers
nord de marseille
ces trafics je les connais depuis mais
depuis que je suis gamin n'est pas connu
de période où il n'y avait pas de trafic
aujourd'hui dans ces territoires lorsque
vous habitez 1
un dealer vous voyez un dealer qui vend
sa barrette de shit dans les quartiers
nord de marseille nous ce qu'on voit
c'est quelqu'un qui est capable de
racketter des familles parce qu'elle
appelle un médecin et que du coup ils
ont perdu 2000 euros et c'est la faille
mancelle ça y est la pub je pense que ça
touche et ça blesse celles et ceux qui
habitent c'est à édouard j'ai peut-être
réagi trop fort que je suis très
subjective mais c'est bien sûr mais je
pense très honnêtement qu'il ya
évidemment des limites à del interior je
pense que par exemple on peut pas
inviter même masquer un pédophile qui
veut vraiment et pourquoi est ce que je
vais dire quelque chose ça il avait
invité les personnes qui sont qui en
ferait nier la loi ou alors il faut le
faire avec précaution moi je partage
l'objectif qui était le vôtre qui était
de dire de comprendre non et ça
fonctionne c'est de comprendre on est
sandra murray dans la méthode par
michelin moi je la partage pas leurs
méthodes jacques portas juste c'est vrai
qu'on a été on a été un petit peu fort
avec vous au seuil de maastricht comme
ça voilà j'ai répondu mais après moi je
me pose toujours la question est ce que
ça peut blesser des gens est ce que ça
peut heurter des gens donc mine de rien
il faut se poser la question et saïd
qu'il ait raison ou tort il a posé la
question après nous alors tao des mecs
qui vont dire bah nan j'ai toujours
raison bien tu as les mecs qui disent
'peut-être que saïd il dit pas une
connerie donc ce problème je voulais
poser la question ce soir aux
téléspectateurs et à vous les chroniques
oui mais j'entends j'entends tout à fait
ce que vous dites effectivement mais en
même temps on peut pas reprocher aussi à
la télévision une forme d'entre eux soit
donc quand on est entre soi et qu'on
parle d'un sujet qu'on ne connaît pas
forcément si ce n'est pour l'avoir
étudiée dans les livres dans l'est dans
les reportages des autres à un moment il
faut aussi qu'on soit confronté à une
forme de réalité pour être confronté à
cette forme de réalité il faut bien
qu'on ait un interlocuteur donc cet
interlocuteur là en l'occurrence c'était
ce garçon là et charge à nous de cadrer
le débat ce qu'a fait cyril de d'opposer
des critiques de questionner qui de
mettre à mal et de recontextualiser mais
voyez ce que je veux dire on peut pas
d'un côté nous reprocher une forme
d'entre eux soit en disant vous parlez
de choses que vous ne maîtrisez pas et
puis quand on en a envie de quelqu'un
qui pour le coup maîtrise même si c'est
du côté obscur de la force si j'ose dire
et bien de nous dire bah ouais mais
pourquoi vous l'invitez mais faudrait
savoir et dans un reportage par exemple
pourquoi ce moment là on prête au point
pas du doigt les multiples reportages en
immersion
dans le jt ou dans les rues
il faut faire la différence entre des
repentis qui sont sur les plateaux en
immersion vous avez raison la vous
montrer une situation est ce que vous
avez pu faire et je vous le dis je
partage l'objectif qui était le vote
mais pas la méthode est à dire qu on est
quand même sur une émission de
divertissement
il ya cinq
six nations et moi j'aurais aimé et
j'aurais apprécié là j'aurais pas réagi
du coup que par exemple on invite à mina
qui le président lui a parlé qui a eu un
frère assassiné qui aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que si vous ce que je
voudrais que vous compreniez c'est
l'émotion que ça peut susciter parce
qu'évidemment ce qu'est né chez moi est
né aussi sur ces familles là les mères
de famille monoparentale qui élèvent
leurs gamins que leur dis attention
trafic etc et qui parce que les gens
retiennent vous avez une émission qui a
énormément d'impact voit un dealer à la
télé se disent pour passer à téléfoot du
nord
c'est mon métier nous avons regardé
l'émission systématisation la question
chaque sens conception celui qui s'avale
aisée vous pensez bien par exemple quand
on fait le sang contaminé ont nui à des
familles mes enfants à l'école donc
chaque fois on se pose la question on a
le droit de recevoir des gens partir le
mans on en fait pas l'apologie
on a tous ceux du recul si on avait
encensé les jeunes mais tout le monde
les réserves d'usagé
radio juste saïd nous on le fait
toujours dans cette émission on reçoit
tous les camps et puis c'est vrai qu'on
est les premiers à dire aussi qu'au
soudan souvent dans les reportages on
voit tout ce qui se passe de mal dans
les quartiers ou à marseille rarement
ces espaces de bien et on est où le fait
souvent ici dans cette émission me
geraldine alors on remet pense à moi je
remets pas en cause votre sincérité mais
ne remet tait pas en cause aussi la
sincérité cyril est la nôtre parce que
ce n'était pas une propagande en fait on
n'était pas dans une sorte de je sais
pas ce que je dis non mais y avait ici
il y avait ce côté là et est aussi vous
il faut pas sous-estimer aussi en fait
comment fait on ce bayonne on met la
poussière sous le tapis on se met des
oeillères ça n'existe pas attention et
dénis la réalité et il ya quand même un
contre-pouvoir on était tous là raymond
a été très très très véhément moi je
pense qu'en tant que parent c'est bien
d'être aussi devant sa télé et de voir
que ça existe et il vaut mieux toujours
voir que ça existe comme un lanceur d'
alerte en fait ça sert de lancer en
al'air cette émission et je pense que ça
a toujours été positive de parler en
fait guillaume balas télé ce n'est pas
le monde des bisounours la télé c'est
censé être le miroir de la société donc
là il ya un vrai sujet d'actualité sur
les dealers dont journalistique mans
c'est normal qu'on le traite et ensuite
c'est pas parce qu'on montre quelqu'un
c'est pas parce qu'on invite quelqu'un
sur un plateau télé qu'on le glorifie la
série lui a posé les bonnes questions
ont montré juive telles qu'elles sont et
c'est ça le rôle de la télé moi je suis
dégoûté et musulmans parce que lui même
et cette chemise qu'il faut la mettre
surtout pas la télé montre quelques
choses telles qu'elles sont pour que le
téléspectateur puisse se faire un avis
voilà
monsieur la ligue était vous êtes le
seul à avoir porté plainte donc pour
cette séquence est ce que et ont comme
vous êtes député ce que votre voix piste
plus de poids que les autres qu'un
citoyen lambda qui devant la ddt et les
contacts le csa non par contre j'estime
avoir une responsabilité
particulière quand on est élu la nation
de ces territoires où j'ai grandi où se
côtoient ces trafics à longueur de
journées où j'habite où je travaille je
pense que c'est mon rôle aussi de porter
la voix de ceux qui habitent ces
territoires et qui souffrent aujourd'hui
de ces de ces pratiques alors c'est très
subjectif c'est une vie marseillaise et
j'entends ce que vous dites bien sûr
mais mais mais permettait aussi où la
vie marseillaise est maintenant de
savoir roulant sur la méthode je dis pas
pour ça que je dis c'est pas l'une est
librement de ce café échec je pense que
sur l'objectif qui était de comprendre
mais aucun souci là-dessus c'était juste
le respect méthode où j'avais une fois
une problématique entre guillemets c'est
pour ça que du coup je demande au ce et
sept sur conditionné d'un signalement ce
n'est pas une certaine plainte et qui
pourra dire où est la ligne entre
guillemets et peut-être qu aller plus
loin la claque que j'ai tort que j'ai
raison peu importe mais ça permet dans
ce que dirait que ça va remettre en
question c'est beaucoup des tri nations
oui vraiment savez vous avez tort
monsieur le député c'est que la méthode
on peut pas faire meilleure méthode
parce qu'ici on est en direct et si on
doit dire une connerie on voit la dire
en direct et quand on fait venir des
jeunes de vote de ou de votre de
marseille ils nous ont éclairés sur
quelque chose que comme a dit valérie
nous on sait pas on connaît pas on n'est
pas dit leur ont fait pas le chouf on
connaît pas il ya plein de gens qui
savent pas vous c'est votre réalité vous
la connaissez et contrairement aux
autres émissions où ça enregistrés où tu
peux monter coupé faire dire un truc que
le mec il a pas dit là au moins ils ont
dit ils ont donné leur vérité leur vie
moi j'aurais préféré que peut-être pas
ce tweet mais comme vous êtes son
terrain et que vous êtes né là bas fait
quelque chose de bien je sais que vous
faites des choses pour eux mais faites
quelque chose pour vite les sortir de la
situation ces gens là parce qu'à
marseille comme ailleurs dans d'autres
cités il manque de plein de choses il ya
des ascenseurs qui sont en panne ya des
familles qui craignent de geodis ans il
a des gosses qui peuvent pas aller là
des gosses qui peuvent pas étudier non
mais il est donc parfait mais c'est
vachement ne vous rendez compte on a un
député qui est né à marseille qui
connaît ça depuis qu'il est tout petit
donc faut bouger les choses vous êtes au
coeur du problème donc bouger les choses
en tout cas pour moi j'en ai vu plein
qu'on dit oui vous inviter des dealers
pourquoi pas ramener les flics bah oui
d'après ce n'est pas notre boulot si les
faits que voulaient les attendre devant
dans les rames est aussi on va mettre le
film en direct après beaucoup de choses
qui ont été dites avant moi mais il est
là le problème monsieur c'est que je
pense que tout à l'heure vous avez eu un
discours en disant que l'émission
c'était une émission de divertissement
et moi je pense que vous faites partie
des personnes qui parlent de l'émission
sans la connaître et c'est tout à votre
honneur vous faites bien sûr ce que vous
voulez lui doit peut-être qu'il ya
énormément de personnes qui parlent de
l'émission sans l'avoir est juste de
réputation de ce qu'ils entendent et on
dit des choses comme ça fait conseiller
et vous verrez si un jour vous voyez les
missions que à chaque fois la plupart du
temps mais vraiment je lui dis à chaque
fois pour pas trop m'avancer je vais
dire la plupart du temps on a toujours
une contradiction sociaux en opposé à on
est toujours pour et contre et
concernant réseaux sociaux bien sûr
parce que je m'attendais pas on est donc
c'est un an mais je remercie également
de lancer ce débat et de permettre et du
coup j'apprends et j'ai une bien
meilleure opinion de l'émission croyez
le mais je veux dire un mot bien sûr
aller évidemment ravi les d'ascq de
christian clavier nous alors je vais
très dur et déjà qu'ils vous avez sait
pas plus
parce qu'on sait des choses qu'il faut
les montrer je prends un exemple tout
bête le passé militaire lo'jo ya
quelqu'un qui est venu ici qui dit qu'on
pouvait en vendre enfin on a acheté
avoir un faux pas ça n'était à part dont
il ya des gens de la télévision qui sont
pas au courant mais sûrement pas tu n'es
pas tout le monde ya des gens qui l'ont
regardé qui sont des vingt-sept mois la
cible informations c'est pas de montrer
aux gens comment faire des choses
négatives le principe de pleine lune
mathieu c'est les trains qui n'arrivent
pas à l'annoncé pour toi aussi
tu dis non de quoi fêter le b à ba mais
si on fait de la sélection nation c'est
de dire aux gens justement un média
qu'est ce que c'est c'est entre
quelqu'un qui détient l'information est
quelqu'un qui ne l'a pas c'est le
médiateur c'est celui qui bat dribbling
désinformation et ensuite la personne se
fait une opinion médias du cours de
journalisme à moi oui
il a fait des côtes bretonnes